IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
SUPER BOWL ON SUNDAY IS BETWEEN
TWO TEAMS WITH CLASSIC NAMES,
THE BRONCOS AND THE SEAHAWKS.
BUT LET'S HONOR TEAM NAMES
THAT WOULD NEVER MAKE IT TO
THE PROS WITH TONIGHT'S
#FAILEDSPORTSTEAMS.
EXAMPLES WOULD BE THE SAN JOSE
SHARTS.
(LAUGHTER)
OR THE SEATTLE C-WORDS.
OH, GROW UP, THEY'RE FINE WITH
IT IN ENGLAND.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, READY, SET, GO.
YES, JASON.
>> THE CLEVELAND STEAMERS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
POINTS.
RANDY.
>> THE MIAMI SOUND MACHINE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: LED BY QUARTERBACK
GLORIA ESTEFAN?
OKAY, POINTS.
YES, JASON.
>> THE ORLANDO JONES.
>> Chris: NICE JUST ONE GUY.
ONE GUY.
YES, BRODY.
>> THE NASHVILLE PREDATORS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THAT IS A REAL TEAM.
>> MY BAD.
>> THAT IS AN ACTUAL TEAM.
>> Chris: OKAY, YOU ARE SAYING
THAT THEY ARE FAILED
BECAUSE-- THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
SPORTS JOKE SO I WILL GIVE
YOU POINTS FOR IT.
YES, RANDY.
>> THE ST. LOUIS SLAVE OWNERS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WHOA!
>> Chris: YUP.
I MEAN LISTEN THAT WOULD BE A
FAILED SPORTS TEAM.
SO WHILE WE'RE UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH WHAT HE SAID, HE DID
FOLLOW THE RULES SO I HAVE
TO GIVE HIM POINTS.
YES.
YES, JASON.
>> THE PHOENIX FENCE JUMPERS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WHOA.
>> NOT ON JOE ARPAIO'S WATCH.
FAILED.
>> Chris: I WILL ALLOW SLAVE
OWNERS, BUT NOT FENCE JUMPERS.
NO POINTS.
BRODY, YES.
>> THE SEATTLE SUICIDES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> IT RAINS A LOT THERE.
IT RAINS A LOT THERE.
>> Chris: TO BE FAIR, THE
WEATHER IS REALLY OPPRESSIVE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
YES, RANDY.
>> THE SAN FRANCISCO 69ERS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)